Smouse ago right when I bought a pack
welcome back to some out Dark Soul you
bros gave me a lot of tips so now
obviously I'll be so I got here don't
worry about it the adventure of today
max wag continues oh [ __ ] oh come on and
now I can target oh yeah no you serious
thanks for the targeting tent let's do
it again
oh why did I ever what okay where are we
going now be wary of tough any let's not
go down there then Oh
we just got [ __ ] back and a barrel
killed me
Oh Shh Oh Shh Oh Shh Oh Shh where do you
come from okay
we're fine be wary of tough enemy yeah I
can't even trust the message yet no no
no hey how are you man and yet no
playing gate don't you dare touch that
cable again don't you dare touch that
cable all right not [ __ ] down there
that's our [ __ ] shirt I was supposed
to jump down there wasn't I what happens
if I jump down there Russ I I know I'm
the best not the best but hey I don't
think I'm the worst either wait
something bad is gonna happen I'm not
gonna stab those fog wall ahead what is
that oh thanks thanks for the warning
about absolutely [ __ ] nothing but
these messages are just rolls
lizard ahead what is it I don't even
know what a lizard is what am I supposed
to do
oh god this looks scary back I can't go
back that's that's you got a look at on
the bright side breasts we just have to
make it somehow there's arrows there's
arrows okay it's dead you can't hit this
you can't hit that oh that was close bro
oh oh
run Yolo to the holo to the pro loading
it and edit and then get it undone turn
another I don't even get a [ __ ] with
that sense I did it go through go
through go through go through I can't do
it get the [ __ ] message is that ah
come on
here we go
I don't have a good feeling about this
[ __ ] set a ladder you can barely see it
hahahahahaha okay is he still trying to
shoot me you dicks what does he have
against me I'm really nice you're the
problem
oh god don't kill me don't give it whoa
you're one hairy [ __ ] aren't you I like
it alright you can't do anything right
that that did that just ain't fair man
take this spot upside down ah that hurts
he hits me either way man well that went
better than expected and what the hell
kind of jump with that can I do that
[ __ ] no I can't of course that this is
never gonna work
this is never gonna twerk this is never
gonna work this is never gonna do our
battle begins you're supposed to stab
him you idiot it's cool it's cool oh you
missed what are you never swing take
this and this and uh blonde be seven one
time for luck okay and then climb
oh and we're back [ __ ] we [ __ ] me
back don't jump down oh oh I can't take
this I think I have to oh why can't you
climb oh hello
I don't think I'm supposed to be here oh
no it's that [ __ ] guy what if I sneak
behind him oh my god
oh gee I'm alive I think that is the
most luck I have ever had in video games
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ] but
that is [ __ ] bum before he felt
impossible now he's like it's it's like
a hot girl first is like yeah then it's
like oh then it's like did I tell you to
not die we're gonna say compliment him
hopefully he won't attack us and
consider going out on a date and now we
were [ __ ] one okay here comes here
comes target you did everything wrong
everything we practice okay now we climb
that's not how you climb in my book but
I don't write books
oh that's pretty [ __ ] good man
I got a good I got a tactic here I think
it's called being a [ __ ] idiot
it's basically describing my entire
[ __ ] life oh god oh god I could make
this yellow swing swing swing swing Adam
swing swing oh my god oh I feel so
[ __ ] good I feel so good I have - oh
my god I did it I I actually did yeah uh
should I - oh shut up you [ __ ] mouth
ah
so I killed the Beast now get the girl
right huh oh god I don't trust this man
Oh what what does it say Court I don't
care man I don't like that guy uh is he
dangerous no need to hide your reaction
I get that look all the time
I mean it can't it can't be that bad
right
you just gotta cross this bridge method
the the level design looks really cool
God what is that
you cannot be serious just when I
thought we were done thanks for killing
those for me preciate it
now if you just I need I need to go
there please don't hurt me
I'm really nice once you get to know me
you look mighty beautiful may I say
you're quite the majestic beast
oh we're alive don't die please is
uh-uh-uh
beware a bonfire where is the bonfire
where's the bonfire where's the bonfire
why don't over is las a bonfire OSS
please for the love of penis where is
the bonfire where it's bonfire I swear
to God I will cry like a little dick I'm
so happy
while that went [ __ ] great all right
pres I'm gonna have to end this episode
here damn this cave is contains Maine
you're like view one more it's a scar a
coma with today I see you brothers in
the next 1000 births love you